[Music]
Simon Blackburn professor of philosophy
University of Cambridge
Viraj Stein professor of political
science University of Gothenburg welcome
the state of truth where do we begin
you mentioned this morning you spoke
this morning about the connection
between trust trustfulness
and truth could you both elaborate on
that Simon would you like to start well
I think there two aspects I would
separate one is the trustworthiness of
direct observation I think this is
something scientists often think is
simpler than it is obviously
observations are trustworthy I can tell
at a glance there's a glass of water in
front of me other people can tell at a
glance that I've got cancer by looking
at an x-ray or something some things
people can tell which others can't by
observation I can't tell which mushrooms
are poisonous if I go in the woods but
some people can to make observation
trustworthy you have to know how to
interpret it and that can often be quite
a delicate business but it's a business
that scientific education is good at
then there's the question of testimony
trust in what people tell you and this
of course in politics in the news in
newspapers media this is the crunch
today because in the old days we thought
that only trustworthy news reports were
produced now we know that very
untrustworthy things are produced all
over the place and so it's
correspondingly much harder to sift out
trust that's partly an institutional
problem there are countries where
they're trustworthy institutions I think
Sweden is one your press is trusted in
Britain the BBC is probably the best
example because Rupert Murdoch has not
got his hands on it yet
so so it is not yet Fox News one day it
might become so there's no guarantee
that trustworthiness continues and it's
very quick to get lost so I think those
are the two aspects of trust which i
think are very important yeah one is and
one I'm optimistic about our capacity to
make good observations the world one I'm
more pessimistic about yeah I think we
have all the difficulties that we
learned this morning about finding out
what is true but there is a baseline for
this and that is that those who are paid
to discover the truth in some way are
impartial they do not have beforehand
political and ideological economic
interest in finding out a specific type
of story but we can trust them that they
will not sort of tamper with the facts
or interpret things in a way that is
very partisan and this is threatened
from two sources one is of course that
I'm a social scientist we have more and
more think-tanks research institutes
interest organizations that are sort of
paying for a specific type of
interpretation of the facts so if they
at all are interested in any fact it's
only the facts that they know beforehand
will confirm their interest the second
comes from within universities we have a
problem with many scholars especially in
the humanities and social scientists is
sort of fall in love with a theory so
they are neoclassical economists or
institutionalist or behavior list or
post modernist or whatever so what if
they are looking for any facts they are
really in love with the theory they
spent years and years in learning this
theory and the very idea that they would
find any empirical evidence that would
refute their theory is alien to them so
I think that if you are back down from
finding the truth to this idea of
impartiality we have at least within
universities force
strong approaches that deny the
importance of impartiality in impartial
ways of finding the truth post
modernists of course to say everything
is about power
we have identity politics within the
university who say a person with this
specific ethnic or religious identity
can never have a truth that is
commensurate to another person we have
in economics the public choice
orientation saying there is no such
thing as impossible t everything is
about self-interest and there are a few
old-style Marxists left also so there
are at least four approaches within the
university system that is challenging
this idea that actually you could do
research that would refute your darling
hypothesis so we are fighting a
two-front war so who is still
trustworthy that is of course the big
question we have date down this we we
here in sweden my department here in
gothenburg we are engaged in a big
opinion research operation known as the
society opinion media and we asked the
Swedish population year after year we
terrorized them with questioners and
usually the the doctors the fish win but
now and then actually the researchers
are the most trusted one far about
politicians journalists I can say are
very low but it's still I think we are
there is some problem but still the if
you ask people usually university
researchers are still trusted much more
trusted than for example hired guns that
work for think tanks that's across
that's a global there aren't big
differences there that I cannot say
right out of my mind I would guess so
but I think in the United States I think
you have a bigger problem with a
partisan divide about these things than
we have in the Nordic countries yes you
said at some point that you would you
like to speak truth to power is power
afraid of truth Oh many times I mean
this is a famous sentence from a
legendary political scientist Aaron
Wildavsky and I said what people who
work in political science and especially
when you do policy analyst analysis
which policies were expressed or not
you're supposed to speak truth to power
and of course there is there is huge
interest in politics they spend a lot of
legitimacy and energy and money in some
type of policy and if you would stand up
and say no this doesn't work as intended
this this is wasted money or this is not
how things operate according to our data
they're not always that interested in
listening to you let me give you a
concrete example so I study what we call
quality of government which is a
euphemism for saying corruption and and
most people who work in the policy
secretary in our country and all over
the world IQ say they are absolutely
convinced that democracy if you
democratize that would work as a cure
against corruption it doesn't not at all
and this is of course not a welcomed
truth they spend tons of money in what
they call democracy aid which I would
never argue against democracy but it
doesn't work as a cure against
corruption no it's a it's a hard truth
to it's quite fun I don't like it it's
not something I would I would love for
democracy to function as a cure against
corruption but the evidence is simply
not there is this big sorry is this
because there's a confusion between
cause and effect I mean you know as the
Constitution and the founding of the
United States demonstrated in order to
have a working democracy you've got to
have open society you have to have a
free press you have to have trust in
universities and the educational system
which brings people up to understand the
world as best they can and if you don't
have that then democracy simply becomes
a a power struggle in which the biggest
marble wins and the biggest mob wins and
the biggest mob will take what money it
can so so simply one man one vote
is very far down the line from the
conditions that guarantee our working
democracy in genuine democracy but the
question is is there another system that
that would work towards the truth that
would be even better well if you look at
the historical facts we cannot do
experiments you know with history so we
have to use history as natural
experiments but if you look at all the
elite stable democracies in northwestern
Europe they first did away with systemic
corruption in their public sector then
they became democracies it was not the
other way around
take a simple thing if you have few
organized elections but you do not have
uncorrupt
authority to count the votes the
elections will not work look at came
here today for example it's also the
case that in in weak democracies a newly
elected government seemed not to be able
to stand against the temptation to
completely fill the public
administration with the political
cronies if there is an election tomorrow
in Mexico and another party coming
70,000 civil servants will have to leave
the lowest figure we found is Denmark
it's 26 we heard this morning that it's
difficult to compete with liars it puts
you in a quite tough position what is
your answer on that yes I thought it was
very interesting hearing general Hyden
talk about the the sort of bubble of
fantasy that surrounds president Trump
but other politicians as well I think -
sir - a perhaps a lesser extent a Mian
in Britain we pride ourselves on having
had for about a hundred and fifty years
an incorruptible civil service it's
always been supposed to have been like
that and I think to a large extent it
was in bribery and so forth were pretty
well unknown
now nobody's so sure because there's the
revolving door so you become Minister of
Defense
you don't actually receive bribes from
the munitions from the defense
industries but you know that the minute
you retire you can go and sit on the
board and you can be paid make us some
mega bucks to shed a bit of your
knowledge on the on the on the company
that's employing you and that's a kind
of corruption which can feed back into
the actual decision-making if you you
know if the chairman of BAE or something
one of the big armaments companies and
comes and says well you know what the
Ministry of Defence like to buy our
aeroplane by the way I see you're
retiring in a year's time you can guess
the result yeah and I think that's
creeping more more into the civil
service yeah we have this stupid honor
system to try to they say you're not
gonna get much money but you become a
sir how's that so a final question and
then we'll have a few minutes to
encourage anybody of you to ask a
question a very vast question but what
is the future of truth giving that quite
Lumi scenario we got this morning well
it's a wise thing one should never
predict lose what can you say I mean we
may be in a difficult situation with
this that was talking about an American
president very much this morning and but
it may also fade away people will sort
of find out that this is not working
they are making making things up I think
for example in the UK where I have lived
now for two years people will soon find
out that the campaigners for brexit were
promising a mirage the things they were
promising can not and will not be
delivered like the UK could be in the in
the free market without paying anything
or that they could be in the frame
without accepting any any movement of
labour this is like promising the moon
you know it's it's a mirage and they
will soon discover that this was not a
good idea and they will pay a high price
for it it will be a bit too late not my
question anymore well thank you so much
is there anyone who would like to ask
one question oh yeah and you you will
need these two to hear the questions and
there should be a mic somewhere please
yes you're here in the middle excuse me
I need to switch this off take this one
this works ok ok I'm miked up ok hello
so isn't truth like is there any
absolute truth because I think truth is
more as a relative term because as a
society let's say society believe
something is true then it is true for
them it's based on belief right like
truth is nothing but what we believe so
is there any absolute truth
there's truth and then there's belief
and beliefs are often false the fact
that says somebody believes something is
very different from the question of
whether it's true you know I can find
somebody in the audience who believes
that Gwyneth Paltrow is right that you
need to spend two hundred and fifty
dollars on a stone to keep vampires away
well that's what they believe I don't
believe it and I don't think it's true I
don't think it's got the remotest chance
of being true so beliefs are one thing
truths another and of course whole
societies can be wrong in their beliefs
the classic is the Flat Earth another
one is the idea that we earth for six
thousand years old which had a biblical
authority until the 19th century so you
know what a society believes and what is
to two very different things I don't
like the word absolute is a matter of
fact because it suggests that
something's done and dusted and very
often as we heard this morning the
scientific attitude is one of well this
is this is where we are now this is
where the ground ground seems firm at
present but we've we've got to do more
work thank you and we have unfortunately
a very true fact over there that that's
we're running over time so unfortunately
we will not be able to take more
questions but thank you so much both of
you and thank you all
[Applause]